à l'étranger un chiffre terrifiant qui
est confirmée par diverses sources et
qui fait état de 100 mille morts au
moins au mozambique cent mille personnes
des hommes des femmes et des enfants qui
sont morts de faim car voici des mois
que la famine ravage ce pays c'est la
conséquence de la sécheresse qui touche
l'ensemble de l'afrique un fléau qui a
mis le mozambique à genoux obligeant
même ses dirigeants qui sont marxistes a
signé un traité avec l'afrique du sud
aujourd'hui le problème numéro un du
mozambique ce n'est pas tant l'aide
internationale qui arrive de façon
satisfaisante médias plus tôt la
distribution des vivres à ceux qui en
ont le plus besoin le reportage de
philippe rochot et jean-jacques le
garrec
un véritable pont aérien est aujourd'hui
en place pour tenter de juguler la
famine au mozambique jamais la
communauté internationale ne s'est
autant mobilisé deux fois par jour la
toute puissante organisation humanitaire
américaine world vision des charges dans
la province d'un tt 15 tonnes de maïs en
provenance du pays voisin le malade
c'est plus qu'il n'en faut pour nourrir
la région et pourtant on meurent encore
de faim au mozambique
alors nous avons tenté de suivre ces
camions pour voir s'ils s'étaient
d'international était bien distribués
nous ne sommes pas allés bien loin le
convoi s'est contenté de traverser le
zambèze 10 kilomètres plus loin les sacs
de maïs ont été entassés dans un hangar
2200 tonnes de maïs moisissent ici alors
que le mozambique continuent de mourir
de faim car le problème aujourd'hui
c'est d'acheminer les vivre dans un pays
qui n'a ni camions ni essence pour les
distribuer et où la guérilla fait régner
l'insécurité dans les campagnes
un des problèmes majeurs que nous
rencontrons dans les zones touchées par
la sécheresse et celui des bandes armées
et le coupe toutes les voies de
communication et nous ne pouvons pas
apporter aux populations victimes de la
sécheresse les produits dont elles ont
besoin car les bandits armés sévissent
sur toutes les routes du pays au moins
tu assassines dad
résultat on meurent encore de faim au
mozambique surtout à cause de
l'insécurité ces enfants qui attendent
une hypothétique distribution de vivres
sont pour la plupart des orphelins nous
les avons rencontrés au coeur de la
province d'inhambane est frappée par une
sécheresse qui aurait fait plus de cent
mille morts en six mois dans le pays et
pourtant ces enfants sont presque des
privilégiés car ils ont pu gagner un
centre de regroupement
1850 enfants vivent ainsi dans ce camp
qui rassemble plus de vingt mille
personnes la famine a surtout frappé les
jeunes certains sont infirmes et se sont
traîné jusque là avant d'être recueillis
par la croix rouge mozambicaine qui a
organisé la vie du camp
mon père et ma mère sont morts de faim
alors je suis parti j'ai marché très
longtemps et je me suis nourri en
mangeant les ordures dans les marchés
la plupart de ces enfants qui grelotte
dans le froid de l'hiver austral manque
surtout de vêtements certains au ventre
ballonné porte encore avec eux les
traces de la famine la mortalité
infantile est ici l'une des plus fortes
d'afrique 150 enfants sur 1000
n'atteignent pas l'âge de 5 ans
le taux de mortalité est pourtant légère
régression ici à l'hôpital de visan
coolos cinq enfants mourraient chaque
jour de malnutrition aujourd'hui grâce à
l'aide internationale
il en meurt un seul par jour ces deux
jumeaux famélique par exemple pourront
être sauvées
si ces enfants restent dans leurs
villages ils meurent de malnutrition car
il n'y a aucune aide sanitaire mais
s'ils peuvent être amenés jusqu'ici nous
parvenons à les sauver par la méthode
lait sucre et huile on leur en donne six
fois par jour
rarement la communauté internationale se
sera autant mobilisé pour un pays mais
si les assiettes reste parfois vides
c'est que le mal est plus profond pas un
seul jour de paie en dix ans
d'indépendance alors si le mozambique a
accepté de signer la paix avec l'afrique
du sud le pays de l'apartheid c'est
d'abord parce que ses fils criait famine
ça